يعني
واحده من المستجدات اللافته الدخول اول
وفد عربي الى مناطق المعارضه السوريه وهو
وفد مصري يضم تقنيين لديهم خبره في يعني
البحث عن الناجين تحت الركام وايضا ضمن
القسم الاخر من الموافد مجموعه من
الاطبالي المشاركه مع الكادر الطبي في
المستشفيات الرئيسيه في ريفي ادلب وحلب
هذا هو اول وفد يعني عربي يدخل الى مناطق
المعارضه السوريه خلال تفاصيل نتبين بان
هذا الوفد خالد دخل من مناطق النظام وهو
ما يعطي مؤشرات بان يعني الطرق قد يعني
تفتح امام الوفود الاخرى الراغبه بالدخول
الى المناطق المعارضه باستخدام يعني
المطارات الاساسيه المطارات الخاضعه لنظام
من خاصه مطار دمشق وحلب للوصول الى يعني
مناطق المعارضه المنكوبه ايضا في
المستجدات هناك حوالي 100 جثه وصلت الى
معبر باب الهوى هذه الجثث هي لسوريين قدوا
نحضهم خلال الزلزال الذي ضربه تركيا
واغلبهم من انطاليا يعني يعني فارقوا
الحياه في انطاليا
عنتاب حيث يتجمع السوريين بكثره فيها
هاتين
مدينتين يعني معبر باب الهوى لا يزال
يستقبل الجثه الثوريين الذين قدروا نحبهم
في زلزال تركي يعني داخل الاراضي التركيه
اما في الداخل الى تزال عمليات
ازاله الارقام مستمره وتتركز بشكل كبير في
بلده جنديرس الكرديه التابعه لمدينه عفرين
اعداد القتلى كان حمزه حوالي ساعتين 580
وهو اعلى رقم
للقتله في اي بلده سوريه
وهذا العدد مرشح للارتفاع على سيما وان
يعني الدفاع المدني ضاعف جهوده وايضا وصلت
يعني مساعدات من الاهالي وايضا لربما
الفريق المصري يتجه الى هذه البلده يعني
نتوقع ان ترتفع اعداد يعني القتل في هذه
البلده الصغيره التي كان يقطنها حوالي الى
اي بلده تحديدا جمعه يتجه الوفد المصري
يتجه الى بلده جزيره جنديرس هو يعني وصل
الى حلب الاجزاء الواقع تحت سيطره
المعارضه وقد يتجه الى بلده جنديرس التي
يعني يعاني فريق الانقاذ من صعوبات كبيره
في الوصول الى كل المباني المنهاره وعددها
84 الف طبعا انا اتحدث عن المباني السكنيه
بينما المباني التجاريه والصناعيه مع
المباني السكنيه عددها حوالي 320 الف عفوا
320 مبنى منهار في هذه
المدينه فرق الانقاذ وصلت الى حوالي 25
الى 30
بعد ان ضاعفت جهودها لكن لا يزال هناك
حوالي 54 مبنى لم يعرف عن
العوائل الموجوده تحت انقاضها ايه معلومات
وتتضاء الفرص امامهم للباقي على قيد
الحياه اذا الجمعه انت تشير الان الى ان
هناك وفدا مصريا دخل الى عبر احد المعابر
التي تم فتحها يعني دخل الى بلده جنديرس
تحديدا
هو هو وصل الى مدينه يعني الى الجزء
الشمالي من مدينه حلب الواقع تحت سيطره
المعارضه يعني من المرتقب ان يتجه الى
بلده جنديرس لانها يعني الاكثر تضررا في
جميع المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره المعارضه
السوريه طيب